we thought we might have fun with a
little mystery of our own
a true crime
okay earlier our very own ross matthews
committed a crime
[Applause]
[Music]
i know it's shocking he stole one of the
station call letters from the drew's
news set
but we don't know which city's call
letters he took bffs we've selected one
of you to be our drew crime detective
and help us solve this mystery charisse
you've been selected
i'm so glad that you and i are partners
on this are you ready to solve this true
crime
i will try okay good just so you know
i don't know what it is either so i'm
going to be playing along with you for
real and we're going to share clues
throughout the show about which city's
call letters ross took
and sharice if you can correctly
identify the city during our final
segment
then you and all the other vfs are gonna
win
the lockley vision a smart lock
featuring a doorbell
and a camera worth three hundred and
ninety nine dollars each
all right cherise you and me we're in
this together let's see if we can do
this
all right let's see the first clue
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay i love that i'm again
i'm really seeing this with you for the
first time so i'm loving this all right
i don't
i don't know if i get it but that i
don't know if i get it from that one
picture sharise do you have any ideas
oh my gosh no
all right we're going to figure this out
because we want to make everybody win
all right stick along and see if you can
solve the drew crime along with us
charisse i'll see you in a minute
it's time for cherise to help us solve
our true crime
all right sharif hi charissa been the
best partner in crime huh pun intended
all right i'm so excited let me see all
the clues one more time
quickly clue one yep rossi on a tower
so i know that's like rocky sure let's
look at clue three which is my favorite
picture
dude you're definitely on a cheesesteak
but
no marinara on cheesesteak no
i am with you sharif that's weird okay
so
which city's call letters do you think
ross
stole for the entire vffs
to get their new camera lock worth four
hundred dollars
oh my god i hope i get it right because
we just
we just bought a new house and we're
changing out the doors
and we would definitely need this oh my
gosh
no pressure is it philadelphia i hope
you got it
[Applause]
you did it oh
[Applause]
oh my god i'm so excited thank you so
much it's been the best day
ever oh charisse and you and all of the
vff's won
a locally vision the smart lock
featuring a doorbell with a camera worth
399
dollars to keep you safe from drew fry
[Music]
when i come knocking you'll know about
it um charisse you said you just uh
moved into a house yes yes my husband
um we're used to be military he suffered
a stroke
and um we've made this our home we are
getting it um renovated to make it
accessible for him because he's in a
wheelchair and
yeah so this is great all right well we
want to give you five thousand dollars
just to get you know
any little things that you want
oh this is
are you serious yeah crime pays charity
i don't want to do the ugly cry no tv oh
that's the only kind of crying i know
charisse
i also want to send you um a personal
item i
i just developed this kitchen line
called beautiful
and i'm going to send you something with
a handwritten note just to
have in your kitchen and when you look
at it i'll send you a toaster oven
or an air fryer i'll send you a bunch of
stuff just so you can have it
because it really is pretty it's called
beautiful for a reason so
um we're gonna just send you a whole
bunch of stuff thank you charisse
well done
okay well we'll see you soon and
everyone stay
safe and we'll see you soon hopefully
you